[Music]
listen check this out I do see to reese
witherspoon he's explaining why there's
double the trouble
this is Marilee and she's my devil don't
we live the life okay that's Reese and
that's Marilee we do we totally look
like we totally do that means in shots
like this from just like heaven you've
got Reese inside the truck and outside
for the aerial it's Marilee that's
nobody
they met on 2003's legally gone to when
Marilee was a background extra
everybody's alike
so she became my devil for more
dangerous shots like in hot pursuit
Reese has called on stunt double Barney
II most stars have stunt doubles the
rocks is his cousin ten oh I read the
will he's been an incredible partner and
brother to me
he's been doubling Dwayne his entire
career including this scene in pain and
gain as a reward for all the risk-taking
two weeks ago the rock surprised him
with this enjoy your new truck and we're
sure Melissa McCarthy appreciates her EE
Luci Romberg an identity thief that's
Melissa and that's Lucy on ghostbusters
Melissa the boss Melissa
see I've only had to go to the hospital
once satisfied in mr. and mrs. Smith it
wasn't always Angelina as mrs. Smith
that's Angelina but that's the leg of
photo double Kate clerk and if you don't
need her face or she's not speaking just
why not use someone else definitely
Batman George Clooney agrees I had a guy
who wore the nipple suit along with me
this is why Superman works alone
you